foreign
hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from MKBHD and welcome to another
high definition video tutorial and today
I'm going to be showing you how to
download something uh the one thing that
might actually have the power to pull me
away from Google that was introduced at
today's
WWDC keynote by Apple 2010. I know this
isn't the iPhone 4 or anything like that
but this is uh the first few minutes of
the Safari Safari 5 page going live I've
been with chrome for a while because of
extensions but if you look over here you
can tell this page is new just because
the little new logo kind of chops off
introducing Safari 5 and it still says
to 54 at the top and this is not really
a very good looking website right now
but I'm going to try out Safari 5 I've
uninstalled a previous version so today
I'm going to be showing you exactly how
this works and giving you a mini review
so go ahead and hit the free download
button at apple.com Safari download I'm
going to download Safari 5 for XP Vista
or 7 and hit the download now button uh
so keep in mind this is something uh
you're definitely going to want to check
out a lot of the new features one of the
new features is cover flow for history
and another feature is uh reading
without distractions it'll automatically
detect whether or not you're on a page
with an article and if you are it'll go
ahead and uh highlight that article
remove it and let you go ahead and
pretty much view the fact that you're in
an article by itself hide all ads in the
background just go ahead and show you
what you need to see which is just the
text
so this installer.exe will finish
installing you don't have to worry about
where it is as long as you can click on
safarisetup.exe I'm going to go ahead
and exit out Chrome we'll go ahead and
see how I like Safari 5. hit that run
button I'm gonna wait for the installer
to come up
so first the windows installer is going
to launch and go ahead and get pretty
much a standard installation screen
they're going to hit next a couple of
times you're going to hit accept a
couple of times this isn't really a very
new process I'm just showing you guys
what it'll look like the first time you
get it install a desktop shortcut sure
why not and uh I don't want Bunger I
don't like Apple software in the first
place so hit yes if user account control
does happen to prompt you for anything
in Windows 7 or Windows Vista and it'll
go ahead and computer your your space
requirements make sure you have the
appropriate video card to use cover flow
make sure you have the appropriate video
card for top sites and Etc and all those
other different things so once you're
finished your status will obviously
finish to the very back the status bar
and we'll go ahead and open Safari for
the first time on this uh when this
installer finishes which it looked like
it should be right about now
or maybe it'll surprise me and go
through it again yes of course
so validating install
now of course if you had a previous
version of safari installed you're going
to have all your bookmarks will be saved
and will actually appear because of
program files when you uninstall Safari
Apple doesn't actually like to wipe your
program files so all you have to do is
just uh well you'll have all your
bookmarks from the last version of
safari if you did use it if you haven't
ever used Safari on your computer it'll
be a fresh install and you won't have
any of that so now that the Safari has
been successfully installed we'll hit
finish to uh open it up and we actually
have to restart our system for this to
take effect we'll hit yes or hit no uh I
guess we'll go ahead and hit yes to
restart and I'll see you in a few
all right so ladies and gentlemen what
we've just done is a quick restart one
of those fast reboots of Windows 7 you
guys know how fast that is and what we
have here on our desktop is a shortcut
for Safari 5 and what we're going to do
is double click and open it for the very
first time on this Windows machine see
if there's anything special I remember
in Safari 4 there was a neat little boot
animation just for the first time you
opened Safari which is pretty cool uh
we'll see if anything like that goes
down for Safari 5 that would be pretty
cool also the first boot of safari does
take a little bit longer since you're
obviously retrieving old program files
digging through your system to make sure
you've got everything Safari needs to
work properly and so here it is it looks
like it's opened in a 1280x720 window
and here is Safari 5. now I won't go
very much into depth from here but you
obviously still have the top sights
button it kept my google.com as the home
page it looks like the top size button
has changed a little bit looks a little
bit more like a keynote you can also
search history down here in cover flow I
don't have much of a history yet in
Safari you can also hit the the edit
button at the bottom left hand corner
and have a small medium or large bunch
of thumbnails as you can see these are
videos that I plan on doing in the near
future so anyway that has been my
overview of how to get Safari for uh I
guess I'll go to Engadget
dot com just to see uh the Safari reader
does look cool oh they brought back the
progress bar that is neat that's very
cool that they brought back the progress
bar so we'll click on this enormous
iPhone 4 article and uh you'll see that
it does look pretty good we're going to
go ahead and check out Safari extensions
we'll check out HTML5 enhancements and
support we'll check out the reader and
everything like that but either way this
has been a quick overview of safari 4
and I hope you guys enjoyed it so thanks
for watching and I'll talk to you guys
in the next video peace